brazil's battle against a dangerous
coronavirus variant could be a warning
for the united states brazil's hospitals
are at the breaking point under a
skyrocketing number of new cases
the surge is being driven by a more
infectious strain known as p1 it
originated in brazil
and already has been found in more than
half of these united states manuel
pojorquez is in brazil's
hard hit sao paulo mandy good morning to
you
good morning tony the situation here
really is dire when the p1 variant
started to take a hold last month more
than half of the states here in brazil
were already reporting icu capacity at
90 percent or higher
we got an inside look at how the
situation is pushing the health system
to the brink
every single patient at sao paulo's
villa pentiado hospital
suffers from covet 19. there's no room
for
any others in your experience how many
of these
nine people in this one room will
recover or not
less than half will recover surprisingly
dr daniela de jesus says more and more
of these patients are in their 20s
30s and 40s unlike icu's in the u.s
these wards are open no barriers between
patients
you really get the sense of worst case
scenario
being in this hospital this room people
are being intubated in the other room we
saw someone
getting chest compressions it's a daily
struggle that haunts those working here
you're the last person they see before
they die
scientists believe a variant that
originated in brazil
known as p-1 is helping to fuel the
surge here
dr miguel nicoles is a professor of
neuroscience at duke university
for sure p1 is 2.5 times more
transmissible and more infectious
why should people in the united states
care about what's happening here well if
i were talking to someone in oklahoma
i would tell him or her be very worried
about it
because if brazil is out of control the
world will be out of control in a few
weeks
because variants they are brewing here
every day every week
they will escape he says he spoke out
about the worsening threat months ago
but few listened
most notably president jail borsonaro
who has been criticized for downplaying
the pandemic
and fighting restrictions put in place
by some governors like sao paulo's joao
doria
we are fighting against two virus
at this moment the coronavirus and both
of narrow virus
doria has drawn the ire of bolsonaro's
supporters but believes the limited
restrictions he's been able to enforce
like closing shopping malls have started
to show results
we needed this moment to be united
against the virus
not divided are you still advocating for
a lockdown right now
we are applicating lockdown right now
we're having the red
face at this moment it's a lockdown a
local
lockdown to preserve lives
and to oriented people to stay home
at this time please stay home
just yesterday brazil's senate launched
an official investigation into
bolsonaro's handling of the pandemic
which could lead to a referral of
possible wrongdoing
to law enforcement the health ministry
here says so far just roughly three
percent of the population
has been fully vaccinated gail really
good point you made there manny
that just because it's in brazil doesn't
mean we shouldn't worry about it here
we are definitely paying attention thank
you very much